my mentor fired me and it was one of the
it was one of the most loving things
he's ever done
he was like i couldn't make a decision
whether i was going to stay in texas or
go to l.a he's like let me make this
very easy for you you're fired well
that's not quite the same
i want to hear the story of why my
firearm what was terrible is this going
on the shows
i just was why did you get fired mike
bethel well so i wasn't
fired technically i was moved to another
team and to be clear
blurry by the way i just want to point
that out it's it's what happens when i'm
being honest
i'm real i
yeah the honesty the honesty is just off
the charts now sometimes
i was yeah i was moved i was moved uh
off his team and and fair play i then
actually
applied for a job with him again and
found myself back on his team so fair
play to nick but no it was um
it was i was just a dick my first job i
just came out fresh out of uni
and was convinced i was going to be the
one to save the games in the stream
and i have met a few people like i
walked around telling everyone exactly
how it should be
and yeah it's you know pissed everyone
off around how old were you
and uh oh i was fresh i used i was like
21 yeah 22
yeah yeah i had no excuse i was far
older than that i was 30
i feel like i've met a number of people
who are like fresh out of uni and and
hit up twitter because they hear that's
how you network in the games industry
which is true
so much of the games industries and then
they just tell everyone that they can do
[ __ ] better than them and i'm like not
gonna 100 have been i don't get annoyed
at those
whenever i see someone doing that also
when someone does that to me i don't get
pissed off because i know at 21 i'd be
doing exactly the same i'm so lucky
twitter didn't exist because i pissed
everyone
off um but yeah no i was uh yeah just
wasn't fun to work with and then when
you know was moved to literally away
from the first laws of the third floor
and then kind of learned humility on my
way back down to the first floor of the
studio
is this an it in shortage in that
building in shortage
or a different place oh no this is way
back this is a blitz this is a blitz
um so yeah that was years and years ago
no longer there actually
but like a very cool uh british game
studio that did a lot of license games
was a lot of people's kind of first jobs
like
or you know basically if you if you like
any triple a game
that's got british people working on it
probably someone on that game
was a blitz like stephanie was like a
training ground for a lot of us
did mike bithell just tacitly set us up
for this week's topic like
beautifully or are we going to move away
from the time i did have a topic in mind
which ties into this
that's what i'm thinking there are so
many there are so many i feel like
there's so many
relevant uh what happened in the
industry in the last
three weeks while we were philosophy
we're we're talk yeah
yeah we're talking about philosophy
right you guys
well i guess i'll introduce this show
that three-ish minutes then
hi everyone i'm alana i'm a video game
writer this is play watch listen by the
way
that's trey baker who is a video game
actor that is mike bithell who is a
video game director
and that is austin wintery who is a
video game composer
it feels weird now doesn't it did i ruin
it is the show like yeah that's weird i
liked i liked uh
there were some comments in the um on
youtube from
this last one that said something like i
feel bad for all the people that stopped
listening after 15 minutes when they
intro the show not knowing that there
was like another hour to
to follow yeah it's [ __ ] felt i
know i like it legit criticism yeah it's
fair um
of which we take very little which we've
spoken about before because it's all
over the place uh
some people did go and leave us nice
reviews on uh apple though as requested
um so i made the effort to read over
those for the first time
so a lot of the reviews are really
really nice so thank you to everyone who
did did you enjoy the
the troy fellatio i did see the troy
fellatio back-to-back
yeah i'm gonna hire that person that's
christian right speaking no no no no on
the apple podcast
thing that they were criticizing us for
that we this is
the question fellatio was christian and
i actually don't know the answer to that
i i have a question how many people
properly spelled fellatio
i don't think anyone actually spelled
out the word fellatio yeah i'm i'm
perfect
i was i was so worried for a minute we'd
actually be a video games podcast i'm
really pleased this has gone this way
but well i i will i will insert
uh if you like that
in the spirit in the spirit of uh troy
fellatio
a a a cheers to our comrade for his
uh i think what fifth bath denomination
this morning
yeah i think at this point i get a it's
a punch card situation
and i just i get a three free free
shipper
you have free tea that's what they do
hey i'm drinking tea
look at that yeah there you go congrats
to you
it's interesting that the category is
basically all the supporting cast of the
last of us
part two uh so i saw someone post
40 of the baftas of the bafta
nominations
are for sony studios games
uh ghost sushi that's not surprising
it's been a good year for sony i guess
it's better
really thank you appreciate it um
i i did find it interesting and this is
not uncommon with bafta they have a
tendency to kind of go
against the grain or kind of like uh
take an opportunity to
maybe spotlight some some um people that
weren't as as mainstream or as visible
and let people know this like hey this
is an exemplary
uh accomplishment by this specific gamer
studio this year which could be said of
every game that came out in 2020 my god
um but i did find it interesting i don't
believe in snubs
but i did find it interesting that in
the narrative category
last of us two was absent
i've always wondered what the criteria
for that one is who was in the narrative
valhalla was in there which i okay i
understand that one
um well what is the what is the category
do we know how they define it in terms
of
is it like just quality of
narrative like just your story how good
is your story in general
yeah it's not specific to like writing
and that's why it's narrative
specifically
i think i've judged it for after a
couple of times
one year which i what i thought that was
a fantastic it's like it doesn't mean
dialogue it doesn't mean acting best
narrative is the use of story inside of
the game
i don't know what that actual definition
is but when when inside one would
with the most lackluster
acceptance speech ever given for any
award everyone's like i don't even like
writing in games and left the stage
i was like that's all right at this
point they're just like we're so tired
of getting on this stage they were like
corey he was like
you want a track suit on purpose because
you knew how many games you were going
to win
um but i i i looked at this hades
congratulations darren cord that's
that's a
a worthy i i hate the word worthy well
for the record i don't think darren
would be the nominee
for narrative but yes no no no i'm just
i'm just saying for for him being
um yeah that's that's the logan and
darren of the people that i know is
super giant
got it john was kind of like shout out
to them both also nominated
both nominated uh cyberpunk i get
i do really go sushima i get
uh marvel spiderman miles morales
wonderful writing team there i don't
know kentucky route zero
very beloved indie and specifically for
narrative as well
okay i've got i've got to be honest and
say i've not had a chance to play it yet
but i know that
that's a very apparently an amazingly
well-written game like
in kind of a traditional sense as well
yeah game never landed for me
because it feels very american is a big
part of it actually um but i know
i really just kind of culturally i think
so um it's an annapurna game
what else is cardboard done cardboard
computer i feel like they've been
working on kentucky root zero for
a lifetime years and years and years
yeah it's a long process i think yeah
i haven't played the most recent
iteration of it um
i'm happy whenever a studio that's been
working on a game for a really long time
at least gets their recognition
you know it's like that's been beloved
for a really long time so it was
revealed in 2011. yeah when it first oh
[ __ ]
they actually released it episodically
right initially or they released it in
chunks right
yeah i think they released it um yeah in
chunks and now you can actually get the
whole thing as the idea
when did the first chunk land twenty
thousand years ago i think
you're 25 years ago yeah the last ones
january like they've literally been
yeah that's why i've not gone through
yes i went away until it was all in
i want it all in place before i got to
it soon i mean
there's an interesting what does that
mean
troy we can't get them removed from the
list to make room for the last of
like if the game initially came out in
2018 so i can tell you what that means
um because like hades is almost a
confusing one even because
hades i played forever ago in early
access and is now just out
um there's another game that was like
part of the nominees process i don't
know what it was called
fall guys still hasn't been out right
like it's still there i can tell you
it's
when they watch that's that's when they
want to it's the jury's decision
because i've been in those juries and i
won't say which game it was but i've
been in a jury
and i remember this well where we were
i'm gonna try and remove as many details
to make it completely unclear what this
was
um where where it was a game that had
been previously released on another
platform
on several other platforms and now was
on one new platform
and it was up in it was in the running
and and the jury kind of went well
no that's so from my understanding a
year ago or two years ago or whatever
it's not actually up to the jury it
wasn't the last of us by the way troy's
i know that's immediately yeah
when they decide that they want to take
after nominated um with what i was
told so the jury also can make its own
deliberations like with after they're
really good
and this actually plays back into the
whole into the thing you asked about
like what is
what is the narrative category it's
whatever the jury decides it is like
there's
and i like that fluidity because it
feels uh malleable enough that it can
kind of be responsive uh to what's on
the table i remember
uh one year was this last year or a
couple of years ago there was um
in the design category uh this this
really interesting um
pinball platformer one up against like
amazingly like complexly designed triple
a games
because it was just that good and i love
that that's one thing i love about bafta
is that
it can be out of left field that
something kind of comes up
um and if you see awards as a way of
celebrating as
troy said if it's a way of celebrating
the year i think that's a really
positive thing if you see it as an
objective
measure of what the best thing was then
obviously you know hey that's rubbish
and b that's not how you get there
but if it's a celebration in a way that
i think bafta tries to be i think it's a
lovely way of doing it it's also very
very specific sorry
i'm just adding to to mike's comment
that
in my experience both this year and
prior ones
on bafta juries um it's not just
um the sort of flavors that we end up
with
and not really objective but but very
specifically and subjectively to who
ends up on that jury
um you know that it's very much an
amalgam of of
the personalities the the you know
agendas to a degree i don't think
anybody's coming in with this sort of
ideological
i want to not make sure that x type of
game or x type of game developer
is nominated but some of that i think is
inevitable since we're just human and
it's like
i really wanna yeah i really wanna make
sure that this thing that i
really value is uh nominated and since
everyone's talking behind closed doors
like my
my mind has been changed in those where
i walked in very convinced of something
and somebody said you know here's
and whatever their initial motivations
for bringing it up i i thought you know
i wouldn't consider that and and so then
something that
you know i wouldn't have voted for prior
to that jury i ended up voting that's
part of the point
um but i did i agree with the the
nominations list
um so the last of us part two
did make bafta game awards history again
as it seems to
with every single one um with 13
nominations in total
uh against last year's record of 11
nominations held by control and death
stranding
so 13 is now the highest number of
nominations any single game has received
since the
standalone bafta games awards first
began um
so that's it's a few and i you know i
don't feel like we need to get into this
but i can also
understand why that game versus others
would not be
uh nominated for narrative because that
is a the one thing about it that i
didn't um love 100 was
the the tedious nature of going through
that story even knowing it's intentional
and obviously that's subjective
um but i can understand other people
feeling that way for sure um
that also for me i i would say that if i
were
you know the the overlord of all things
to me the narrative category in many
ways you are awesome
in many ways you are the narrative
category um
as like my my voting agenda were i on
that panel and i wasn't but were i on
that panel
um my agenda would be the game which
through its gameplay most interestingly
you know gamified or communicated it's
independently also very excellent
narrative so it's sort of a
and and that's why i look at a game like
um
um you know her story i remember being
fairly certain it was nominated maybe
even one that category i can't remember
but that's that was an excellent example
nominated yeah like
and but it's one where i actually think
the narrative itself
is is solid even very good
but the manner with which its narrative
is unveiled to the player is what makes
it
excellent i do agree yeah cause if you
take the narrative like the story you
know just
written out as a beat sheet you know in
word you're like
it's you know serviceable like you know
it's like an episode of csi it's like a
good
crime mystery of the week but by
sh presenting it this way it made it so
much more
um and simple story complex characters
that that's
that to me this is the quote that i was
driving in the car the other day and the
synthesis i literally wanted to pull
over the side of the road
and and blast this out to everybody but
it's oliver wendell holmes quote when he
says simplicity on this side of
complexity i wouldn't give a fig
but simplicity on the other side of
complexity i would give everything
and that to me is is what is
so brilliant about it is it's it's a
very simple story
but it's on the other side of the
complexity that you find the simplest
that is true
it's the uh in the grand uh the grand
design
stephen hawking book he he he
says essentially what you just said
without without quoting
oliver wendell holmes because he says
the greatest scientific
theories are those which um
have elegance in in their ill-defined
what is that that wasn't really that
wasn't him though that wasn't he
kind of wrote that it was the other guy
well they co-wrote it
um well
we can mitigate that so who knows i take
issue with that book i'm sorry i love
you
why did you just pull out the grand
design mike bithell he did pull out
um i couldn't see what it said into the
woods by john york
mike's just not even trying we're like
the grand design and he's like here's
michael creighton's jurassic park
it's a jesus it is one of the
quintessential it's one of the books i
always recommend people for um
for storytelling so actually it's great
design or or jurassic no
ins into the woods uh the play uh
the play brilliant story well in any
case the
the whether or not troy stands by uh the
authorship of the grand design or not
the point the point made of like using
the quintessential example of e equals m
c
squared as that is the simple
side of complexity you boil down a whole
hell of a lot into something incredibly
simply stated and elegant and
easily understood despite the fact that
an enormous amount of
powerful complexity can come out of
an understanding of it i just can't wait
until
i can talk about what i do for a living
there's so many things that i'm like
would have a comment
and i'm like yes storytelling is a thing
that is interesting is it not
um so
as a for the record for the record
everything that we've talked about for
the last 10 minutes is my fault
because i i uh i i fellated
uh as my congrats uh to troy on the bath
denomination
but you were actually teeing us up to
talk about none of that well i want to
just say
uh now that you've put us on baftas and
and we can't move on from any topic
without every person having
given a lot of an opinion on it um so
the the full nominees for best game are
animal crossing new horizons ghost
tsushima hades half-life alex and
uh miles morales and the last part two i
actually really hope that this one gets
um because with the baftas you have to
play all of the games
um that this one actually gives
half-life alex a bit more of a shot
um because i feel like you know the lack
of access to it has caused problems
previously but i also just noticed and
didn't know this previously that
the baftas has nominees for british game
that's always been there um oh yeah
always 2012 was the first time well i've
been there for a while i should say
and i wanted i was i was i was really
surprised that flavorworks didn't get
nominated
in that category for erica or debut game
either one of those i was really sure
if erica is in some bizarre way
considered to be outside of a video game
like i mean it's published by sony on
playstation that's fair
but i wonder if it's just a perception
that's caused that
death stranding is kind of video that's
true it's like
death training might be less of a video
game than erica
i mean i'm not i wasn't gonna say it but
i'm happy someone did
can we just can we just stop insulting
games toys in please can we be insulting
it's just in the sense that like also
also who insulted the last of us i i'm a
big fan
i advocate for that game constantly
it's it's the if we aren't fellating
troy enough mike takes it as though
we're insulting him that's the roles
that we
want that's what it is don't worry about
it but i did want to give a shout out to
this game that i played really recently
that's on the the
uh british games list called roki um
that i just thought was very sweet
just uh it's a game from a new studio
it's the first game
um sony people yeah really wonderful
little experience it's uh
essentially a point-and-click adventure
game so i would say anyone who
has not played a point-and-click
adventure game you might find it
extremely frustrating but for anyone who
grew up on
your monkey islands um this is exactly
this guy
well yeah you did point at me but but
also austin
you said this guy right ironically to me
i definitely grew up on the monkey
islands yeah i will
i wondered if it would be frustrating
for someone who had never
played an actual point-and-click to jump
into this game because it is you know
how
like there's parts of room fandango
where i was like
how was i ever going to figure out how
to do this particular like
this is absolutely absurd and rookie
does have a little bit of that stuff
which i now oddly have grown to love
even if it is nonsensical
it's funny how when that game got
remastered for playstation
oh sorry i yield i yield to the chair
yeah
i want to i want to plug a game i want
to play a game because you brought
pointy clicks and i played a lovely one
because
no which is just out on switch which is
excellent and everyone should check it
out
no it's such a capitalist game there's a
such a capitalist
it's been a journey this show um
locomotive
loco motive it's on ichio
and it's like this weird it's literally
like an undiscovered lucasarts game it's
a really nice it's one of those pay what
you want ichiyo games it's about two
hours long
it's really lovely and they nail that
exact lucasarts humor like
to an extent where you're like this
might secretly
be you know shaffer and gilbert doing a
little game on the side it's not it's an
awesomely new talented team
but genuinely made me laugh out loud
several times
it was made in two weeks by four people
it's
ridiculous and the game
takes one moment it takes it makes jokes
about that
during the game they're doing the mess i
think it's very lucas arts it's
definitely worth everyone's time it's a
really charming game yeah i
feel like i i you'd love it austin it
would blow you you'd absolutely love it
i i i i no no not at all i
have a uh i have a long-running love of
of point-and-clicks and
even though i i agree what i was
starting to say a minute ago is that
it is funny how i've evolved um
in how i read them like how i clock the
puzzles
because you're not wrong alana that
some of the grim fandango puzzles 20
years later
playing it i was like how did i figure
this out as a teenager
because i feel like i've somehow
regressed in adulthood to finding this
impenetrable like the one that
stands out which is in hindsight it's
hilarious but there's this whole thing
about
you need to steal eggs from the pigeons
on the roof that's the one that i think
is the hottest in the entire game
so okay perfect example that so you go
to
try to steal them and they will like
flock and chase manny away
and so and then but you can you can like
pour
you can carve up breadcrumbs and leave
them in the little basin
on the roof that they will they will all
flock to and but then if you go to the
eggs they'll
they'll always go back to the eggs so
the solution to this puzzle is to go
down to the street fair
and talk to the balloon animal guy get a
balloon from him
um of which one of the options is a
robert frost balloon which is
just excellent tim schaefer in action
it's like you can have a giraffe a
kangaroo or robert frost or whatever
and uh so you have to then go back up to
the roof put the balloon
in the basin then cover it with the
bread crumbs so that when the birds come
and they
you they start feeding they pop the
balloon and they flock and
they get scared and run away and then
you can grab the eggs and it's like
obvious yeah it's it's like they're
really i love that there's
never anything that tells you about the
balloons at any point
nothing ever is like maybe you should
get balloons like no one ever hits it
like it's so difficult it's just the
intuition of it's just relying on you to
just kind of intuit balloons can pop
birds have sharp beaks like you're just
supposed to put two and two together
and on the one hand i do admire the
belief
in the intelligence and the creativity
of the player
but in a world of like game systems
creating predictable trajectories of oh
i see
you taught me to do this and then you
taught me to do this other thing with
this thing and i bet if i did them
together
you know that's we kind of hold the hand
a little bit more now
in a way that is probably better
designed in in some sense but
is also you know i never a little bit
just be figure it out
it used to just be figure it out because
there wasn't another game that was
coming two weeks later
it was just also you could buy the book
you could buy the strategy book
for short first hand 20 buck uh
investment but like the like the
nintendo what was the game power
magazine or whatever that would come out
that would have it or
um but by and large to me was just like
figure it out i would i would be stuck
staring at a screen for hours or
days going i can't figure i mean going
back to like hitchhiker's guide
holy crap yeah those kind of text-based
adventures i was like i don't understand
what i'm supposed to do it was super
young i mean another game that did that
to me most recently some of the puzzles
are absurdly hard
uh call of the sea um never played that
i i've had that installed
in my origins a lot of exposition came
out a lot of exposition going on there
there's a lot of dialogue um [ __ ] did a
wonderful job
uh with especially considering how much
of it there is um but the puzzles in
that game like stumped me
in a way that i i didn't quite realize
how much i love
[ __ ] hard puzzle games until playing
that i was like this some of this is
absurd like i'm looking at and i'm like
i'm never gonna figure this out but you
can consult like the notes that the
character has written in a journal
while at the same time just surveying
the environment put it together but some
of it takes hours like it's
very very very hard in a way that i
found really satisfying
the old point-and-click adventure games
i don't know if this is just my
perception and i guess
you know surely one of us could just go
ask tim
but uh i don't picture it as having
faith in your audience i don't think
that they made those i mean i really
could just message you
doris kept me tim shafer on the line i
don't feel like it was like a
president of show will help them to
figure it out i feel like it was a lot
more of like
well this is the solution eventually
they will figure it out like
how i don't imagine anyone was ever
gonna guess that mike you you are here
but you're out of sync
very off mic it actually looks he looks
i'm a bit scared you're pleasantly good
executed yeah
all right peabody hopefully he'll keep
recording on his end like troy and we'll
get a little easter egg mike episode i'm
going to keep trying to reach mike
bethel we've lost him
uh
keep this recording hey hey sound editor
guy how's it going
yeah i don't feel like they um i don't
feel like they had players intelligence
in mind
i feel like they didn't think about it
that way no i think they're just like
absurdly difficult and they're like
there's a solution in there part of it
yeah part of it was just the vocabulary
of those games that it was
assumed like you look at a game like
mist
that represents kind of the extreme in
many respects where
it's deliberately pretty opaque knowing
that people are going to sit with it
they're going to think sleep on it
they're going to have their pad their
notebook
mike you appear to be reborn very
insightful point austin please continue
i'm glad you liked it no why don't you
why don't you continue actually i'd love
it by the way i'd love your opinion mike
continue go ahead
i think i think i you know what you can
never know
what death will bring you can never know
the life
yeah but ultimately you know all we can
do is teach our children
uh that they need to find their own
paths in life which is what tim schafer
was trying to do with monkey island
which is what tim schaefer was trying to
do he wanted to respect us as players
[Laughter]
mike disappeared for a second to give
context to all of that conversation
he came back it's all okay you should be
watching on the internet wow you're very
um
uh singly today yeah jingle is probably
better
what are you you in a musical type of
mood
i'm always in a musical type i walk
around singing it's stupid like if you
just like saw me in the wild i'm i'm
always doing
the the worst like 80s soundtrack
to i've seen you in the wild and i've
never seen you do the worst 80s
soundtrack so
that's in the team we need to start
doing show tunes on the show i think
that's something that everything by and
large most everything is a country song
to me
you know all because country songs
there's some good ones
but but most they're they're the most
pros they're not so much poetry
um you can just
it's amazing
[Laughter]
now what do you mean by that i kept
waiting i kept waiting
no no no let him finish what do you mean
by that haircut boy what are you trying
to say about my country music
back up boy um okay it looks like we
actually
move on completely i feel like i should
oh you did already read them correctly i
was just going to show the actual
bafta nominees for narrative but i think
i think troy nailed them it is
assassin's creed valhalla cyberpunk 2077
ghost of tsushima hades kentucky root
zero tv edition
and marvel spiderman miles morales
um a lot of good games a lot of good
games a lot of good great games great
games
a lot of good games just in general
games industry keeps doing it
um so i would like to point out that i
think
it is a record i has to be maybe nolan
beats this but i think ashley
does she's been nominated three times
for the same character
wow that's that's impressive but that is
that is worthy of winning
one of those correct winning two she's
the only one that i knew that went
back to back for the same character
what was the for the for um for uh
left behind interesting i'm i'm amazed
that that was
sort of yeah interesting i was going to
say i didn't know that that would count
as like
enough of a standalone release yeah
shipped on a disk would made everybody
else go maybe we should be shipping our
dlc on a disk
wow yeah it was she she was not there
for the first time
um and and i i received on her
behalf and then she came back the next
year and proved why
she deserves all the awards by giving
one of the greatest deceptive
acceptance speeches ever she is very
well laura bailey for the game awards
did the same thing was just like
this is why people like you should win
awards because you take that opportunity
to just
is your moment to shine and you just do
it with such elegant and grace
laura bailey is also nominated um the
one that i would like to point out
shannon woodward by the way
did so much heavy lifting uh in that in
that game
um i will take a just a brief moment to
talk about my fellow castmates
jeffrey pierce as tommy
um is i i i cannot begin to express to
you
the amount of skill
that he deftly wielded
through the entirety of that processing
game
and there's there's so much he he is one
of the most gracious
devoted flowy i i i could not have asked
for a better person to play
opposite of or have
i can't see anybody else in that role
anybody he he brought literally brought
tommy to life
um and he is i'm so glad to see that he
got nominated was he before
uh was he prior for part one
oh yeah tommy in part one nominated was
he nominated
he was not he was not nominated like in
other words is this a is this one of
those
cosmic justice moments of him getting
the recognition that
would have equally been owed
a few years ago when part one came out i
think so
i mean i i definitely think that in my
opinion tommy's role
in in part two is is way more exhaustive
um yeah fair enough much larger
light yeah but uh
his performances is continuously
it should be studied like it like what
he did i think i've said this before
like if i was going to give anybody and
i actually did this once
if i had to give a single scene from
that game to give us a cross-section of
what
a beautifully crafted scene in a game
could look like
um it would be the farm which is a scene
that i'm not in
that is very good it is just if you
don't need to know anything else about
the story
you just know those three people are
having that conversation and
specifically
ellie and tommy's conversation you've
revealed everything about him it's just
it's it's it's a i don't use this
lightly it's a master class like you
could watch that and dissect it
yeah it's almost a very good standalone
short film i would definitely agree with
that
logan cunningham getting nommed again
just as incredibly talented sweet
human um has hades achilles poseidon
asterious sharon and the storyteller in
hades
it's amazing not fair he's always been i
didn't know that
he he's always been the only voice uh
in super giants games like he's he's
every voice actor in their prior ones
and then this one they just needed a lot
of people
um and so yeah he's he's only like half
the
characters in this one he got lazy he
got lazy yeah exactly
at some point in that career you know
yeah although i do like step back i do
love the irony though that darren is
zagreus that that
that is just too funny it's wild it's
wild there's also patrick gallagher
as or gallagher as cotton khan and i did
really like that performance seems like
a really
really good villain um but i also wanted
to note here and i think this is a
really interesting one
um chirami i'm hope i'm pronouncing that
shirley
yeah jeremy lee as female v in cyberpunk
2077.
i played as female v i actually usually
play as a um
a male character in most games but i
like her voice so much that i did play
as female v
and i was like troy is it weird
if you were to play how do you think the
male v feels
like is that do you think that would be
a really strange thing well like you
know
the same thing with mass effect right
where everyone says your friendships are
really big
like everyone just talks about jennifer
hale's performance to the extent
that mark muir is kind of like like how
can i
are we being mean no i i look to me
this is the thing that i love about it's
not like well okay we have if we
nominate one we have to nominate the
other
there's a reason why you did each
and you did you did it to give a
different
performance you did it to give a
different side of the character
even if it's the same lines that have
been given assassin's creed has been
great a bit doing this um
there's i mean the the whole point of
jacob and evie is is
there's two all the characters yeah that
well that's a that one's a little bit of
a
uh because it's it's kind of a co-op
it's probably it's not two versions of
the same character two different kinds
of two they're siblings they're
literally different people
cassandra and the brother whose name i
don't remember again because everyone
loves cassandra so much
it's probably a better example yeah yeah
yeah or valhalla valhalla
did that yeah um avior and
ivor the other one i thought that sounds
right yeah
oh my god i have r you gotta watch
vikings so good
um but i know i i think it's it's to me
is
the the the actor
whoever did whoever landed it better
i think some characters work better as a
female some characters work better as a
male and it doesn't mean that you have
to do both i think that it's just for
this story that we're telling it
resonates more as a female it resonates
more as a male
or even better you know you have so you
have game like inside where
you choose is it a boy or a girl there's
nothing inherently that tells you
um that to me was a was a brilliant
choice
so paddy mike
i was just gonna say no one should feel
bad for not getting nominated for an
award
no that's it's always a very limited
pool of things like no one
it's it's of course if you you know if
you know that you might be up for
something and you find out that you're
not of course that's gonna be
disappointing but like
you know it's it's all very silly it's
all absolute nonsense
until you win one then it's the best
thing in the world and then it's
absolutely nonsense you have to
celebrate the things but you're right
your worth and your values should not
ever be tied to awards i still strongly
agree with that um there's also a long
history of
acclaimed artists you know
like like the list of you know legendary
musicians that never won a grammy for
example
you know and it's not it's not b
side people you know it's like hendrix
uh
and there's there's and someday you'll
make the departed and they'll give you
an oscar
just to apologize yeah yeah i mean
actually
speaking of troy's favorite artist of
all time one of my favorite oscar
acceptance speeches was randy newman
winning winning for uh monsters inc
where he basically
was like you basically was like really
for this game
um because he was so uh he was so
uh he didn't win for toy story no that
was the thing
it was like how did i not he basically
said that in his oscar speech for
monsters inc he was like
for this one not not last time just were
clear right like he was so
he was so baller oh yeah he doesn't give
a [ __ ]
it's too funny uh any of you watch the
golden globes
they had those same like that's my whole
attitude is like i didn't even
know it was i think as i understood the
best thing that came out of golden
globes was
uh what's her name from queen's gambit's
dress yeah it was pretty cool i saw
photos
she looked at like jessica rabbit went
that but in green
that have any of you seen that show
queen's you haven't seen the show i i i
gave up on it
i didn't like it i didn't either i
didn't like it either and everyone else
i know
you know yeah you're nuts i think it's
fantastic you and me then against the
world because i
don't understand that she tries
because everyone loves it she's amazing
she is amazing it to me
it was um and again everyone else i know
loves it so i recognize that i'm an
outlier
a show about absolutely nothing like i
did not feel like i was driven to
continue to watch it i didn't feel like
i was watching her grow
she seemed like she was the same for a
very long time i was like what
am i supposed to be attached to in any
of this it was just like you like chess
what i also didn't know what she wanted
as a character there was no motivation
or journey or learning have you ever
watched boardwalk it was just a person
having a series of bad
interactions with people you're just
like just going to therapy
i love this because to me it is exactly
what you're talking about and that's
what i find compelling
because it is a story about obsession it
is a story about
identity it is a story about not knowing
who you are until the
very last moment no she seems to always
know that is it a story about obsession
though
is it a story about obsession because
like i agree with you the character is
obsessed
that's present but like it doesn't it
doesn't have an opinion about what
obsession does
her obsession doesn't how do you know
except what are you talking about it
will make you an alcoholic
stop drinking whenever you want to it'll
well it's not though she's fine at the
end
isn't she well like she tries through
like watches
she goes to e3 she comes back she's a
little bit knackered but ultimately a
couple of weeks later she's back
the whole first part is her showing up
waking up drunk then she's fine with no
consequences for that
she loses that game and then moves on
with her career
i'm not saying it's not realistic i'm
saying it's not to me it's not
compelling storytelling
yeah i i feel like that am i talking
absolutely nonsense
no no no i wouldn't agree but what
you're describing what you're describing
to me
is the act 2 closer that they
lead off with in the very first episode
that is your entire life has been
culminating toward this moment and you
blew it
and it didn't she didn't walk away and
she got to go back
it it cost her everything cost her
everything what's the
i don't know for about half an hour does
she even really have
like she no for like a year
it's also it's just like in terms of
like tv time it's like half an hour she
doesn't suffer for that
it's a whole it's a whole two other i
don't think we watch the same show
because i i didn't finish it so
i started oh yeah i don't want to ruin
it for anybody but but like mike already
has
all about the redemption and it's all
about the relationships that she built
that she didn't have when she was
younger
it's funny so i i really
i really loved it there was only i i was
talking with a friend
who i thought made an interesting point
about
a potential flaw in the show which
he he said the you know his biggest
gripe was
that she basically this is a slight
spoiler for anybody that wants to pause
uh uh she she well you know what i mean
i'm giving you i'm giving you a heads up
uh come to go to this time code yeah
exactly
exactly let's make some work for someone
else later
this time guys do that oh you're going
to want to comment on this guys so get
ready
they're ready get ready they s their
their
observation was she
seems to have this she kind of
burns these past relationships um
and then they they they nonetheless sort
of rally to her side
so there's no real consequence for her
having [ __ ] up these past
relationships and i
i brought that up with a friend who who
was like
just over the top obsessed with the show
and he was like
the reason why that wasn't a problem
with me is because because this was a
guy who knows the chess world
deeply he was like a competitive player
and he goes the reason why that doesn't
bother me is because that's realistic to
how the chess community is he was like
there are there are if there's a chance
if they don't ride or die they're like
fast and furious
basically the same yeah they had been
diesel
in the show for a while and then he had
to drop out for schedule reasons
uh yeah no it was he he his argument was
like
the people in the chess world are so
obsessive about the chess that they will
get over
like it is not a leap that they would
get over their own little heart
literal heartbreak if they have the
chance to help her
beat a grand master who's never been
beaten before kind of thing
and i would like to believe that that
that actually doesn't fall flat with me
as a as an idea because they're
they're all so obsessed and i've also
had people that i
have believed in me more than i believed
in myself at the moment and they were
like if you could just
get your [ __ ] together you could
accomplish
what we can't and that's what it was
there's a lot of
of vicarious living things like you're
the one you're the chosen one you know
you're you're the one that could
actually go all the way with this
we didn't have it in us and so we are
rooting for you so that
together we all could succeed the thing
that i love that they didn't do was do
the
the rocky iv it's drago versus rocky
you know [ __ ] and it's it there's
such a mutual respect
oh my favorite people favorite moment is
again spoiler but in that
in that one elevator when she's in one
of her when she's in one of her finals
uh one of the final matches against like
the old timer the guy with a huge beard
and she beats him and he just smiles and
he's like
beautiful excellent he loves how she
beat him like he's so it he admires her
that you know he's this is a massive
level
world champion and he just delights in
the method of her victory and i thought
what a beautiful
lovely moments and if and i agree with
you and i think and the the
cinematography is beautiful
the costume design like kerry every
single dress
she the main character came in and carey
was like i need that dress like every
single one like it's
it's a shopping list if you're ready
it's christian to your love you know we
can
you know maybe switch sells well you
know but ultimately
um but like but like
it that's the problem is those moments
are lovely but they just don't
to me they don't like i thought the
first couple of episodes were pretty
strong like the the whole narrative of
the kid learning from
from the janitor and like that arc they
go through
those two characters but the second
spoilers again
the second that character is not around
anymore there's just
no i think that's about the time when i
stopped watching too and
i just i just don't have tolerance for
tv shows that i'm not super into the
minute that i feel like it's not worth
it i just stopped watching them
completely
um and that that was my problem it's not
i didn't feel like i was rooting for her
in any really significant way probably
as
a result of the lack of relationships
like the relationship that she has with
her mother was not one that
i don't know foster mother i suppose was
not one that inspired me whatsoever
again i loved that because it was a
complicated relationship like they were
they were
it was messy that wasn't this idyllic
mother-daughter thing
see i don't want that oh i don't want
that i don't want an idea
it's just uh but nor was it a caricature
of the mother who parades around her
gifted child like
pageant pageant mother type that was
nice again that was nice
but what does the main character of the
show want
and what do they need i mean i'm i'm not
going to give it away i just don't know
i feel like that is interpretive but
yeah
if you haven't watched um
boardwalk the thing that boardwalk
empire did
is how do you
get five seasons out of a show where the
main character
doesn't have an arc until the last
season
you want to talk about a character that
never changes
that is completely irredeemable from the
first frame
and then you choose season five to go
now will do you it is
there are some shows i pushed against
the wire for this i'm like
don't present a show to me that is such
a high buy-in
that looks down their nose at me because
you can't understand what's going on in
the first five minutes
i did the same thing with the wire twice
i was like i'm out
but that's not what the show is designed
to do it's not designed to be
easily palatable it's like we're telling
an epic we're going to be doing it
over multiple things it's not about you
liking this from the very beginning
i respect it it goes back to the games
we're talking about mcnulty
wants to be a good cop and he needs to
be a good man and you that's your
basis for that's your emotional core of
the story even
even with all of the obtuseness which
you're talking about like there's
there's stuff going on with those
characters and with their journeys and
their growth and i just i just
yeah i think that's a little reductive
because it's not even it's
massively redundant it's like the core
of something much bigger for sure
but you need an emotional heart to a
story you need to
i need something so i'm rooting for them
right but he's not who i connected with
but that to me the interesting thing is
you start connecting with the drug
dealers
of course yeah yeah right exactly yes a
string of bell like again like string of
bells
is this brilliant flawed kind of
shakespearean kind of
he's doomed because he wants to be this
amazing businessman but all he knows is
the world he's
yeah these are but this is the thing is
these watch the wires
watch the wire watch watch the light no
one plays challenges
i was going to say there's no chest in
the wire but there's a pivotal chess
scene isn't that where
they explain the pawns and the king and
the uh string of bell dude
i i would i would uh after we have seven
seasons of west wing in front of us
and and i would uh no you have four
seasons of the west wing and then you
can probably move on
is that true yeah did it get a little
bit long in the tooth
no it's it's it's it's it's i'd say it's
great it's it's genuinely
great if a little sanctimonious for the
first like three seasons and then you
have there's i think they run for like a
presidential
i think it's like a the re-up or
something they're going they're running
again for the
for the primaries and everything it just
kind of yeah it drifts at that point
for the first kind of three seasons i
think the the moment
for me the moment where you should watch
till you should watch past this of
course and form your own opinions but
the moment where it peaks
or where it starts to decline i guess is
um there was a
september 11th episode all right i'm
sorry season one season one so i i
i figured that we would get there just
from the short timeline i can say this
and i'll i'll
happily uh rescind my my control of the
floor
um i've i don't think i've ever enjoyed
martin sheen as much as i have in this
he's great yeah and there was there was
a scene where there's not a wasted line
of dialogue and everything is incredibly
intentional but there was
there was one episode where they're um
trying to decide if someone's going to
live or dies on death death row or
whatever
and the president literally is like
polling everybody and
he brings in his father from his parish
his priest from his parish
and the priest played by carl maldon
goes
i don't know what to call you do i call
you jed do i call you mr president
he said mr president would be better and
it's like and the priest goes oh
okay he goes i need to understand it's
not for what you think but inside these
walls in this office there are decisions
that i have to make
where who's going to war how much money
do we spend to cure this disease or
who's going to live or die and it's
better for me if the office is making
those decisions and not the man i was
like [ __ ]
and at the very end of the scene so
they've been calling him
the president calls his priest tom
the entire time tom i'm glad you're here
he goes mr president thank you for
having me
at the very end the priest goes jed
would you like for me to hear your
confession
and the president goes yes father i
would and it's just like
yeah adam's great dialogue that is best
it's such a good show
it's such a good show yeah and it's
never happy handed it's always just like
it's served up if you get if you didn't
find we're moving on
bam bam bam that's that i almost made a
bad joke that brought us back to the
reason why
anyway go ahead a lot of peers
completely unedited episode everyone
there's no
cuts at all nobody made it
that made their face go bright red and
it wasn't me it wasn't no one's face is
still bright
no one's facing it's completely there's
no evidence of what happened it's all
fine
oh hey everyone it's alana from the
future with actually some pretty good
news we went way over time uh with two
very different topics with
episode 53 of playwatch listen so i have
split it into two parts
meaning this is part one that is mostly
focused on one topic
part two will be uploaded tomorrow with
virtually entirely different topics so
we'll see you tomorrow and also again
next week it doesn't mean you're not
getting another episode next week just
to be clear